die
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt ein tolles gebäck und
zwar weil die florentina machen
von tina haben übrigens nichts mit
florenz zu tun uns falsch ist ein tolles
weihnachtsgebäck und es ist auch
glutenfrei bei mir zumindest als in
manchem rezepten wird auch mehr
verwendet aber das braucht man gar nicht
braucht dazu nur gehobelte mandeln und
noch ein paar andere tolle zutaten und
zwar mit einer rost masse erstellt aus
butter zucker und den mandelblättchen
und die werden dann im ofen gebacken und
typischerweise und traditionell wird es
rund gemacht aber ich find's einfach
etwas aufwendig gerade für zu hause kann
man so ein bisschen praktischer
gestalten deswegen habe ich florentiner
ecken gebacken und zeigt euch mal eben
die zutaten und dann können wir auch
gleich starten
für die florentiner maße brauche ich 175
gramm zucker 50 gramm honig 125 gramm
butter 150 milliliter sahne und 300
gramm gehobelte mandeln die masse muss
jetzt erstmal in einem topf ein bisschen
gekocht werden
deswegen gebe ich jetzt zucker honig
butter und sahne hier rein und lass das
ganze jetzt erstmal aufkochen und wenn
man möchte kann man zu den florentinern
also zu dieser florentiner maße auch
noch kandierte früchte dazu geben wie
orangeat und zitronat oder auch kirschen
oder cranberries zum beispiel ich mag es
nicht so gerne da drin deswegen macht
einfach nur pure man will mit rein
die masse ist jetzt noch ziemlich
dünnflüssig und ich koche jetzt etwa
vier bis fünf minuten bis sie etwas
resigniert und falls ihr ein zucker
thermometer habt könnt ihr gerne
reinstecken und bei 110 grad etwa ist
die masse perfekt dann fängt nämlich der
zucker ganz leicht an zu karamellisieren
und die masse wird ihr heißer in dem
eben jetzt die flüssigkeit so ein
bisschen verdunstet und dadurch wisse
eben auch dickflüssiger sieht man hier
zb schon das schon dickflüssiger wird
jetzt sitzt sie gleich ganz helle karam
entfahren unternehmen perfekt
man riecht das ganze auch also sobald
das leicht karamell farben dahin sobald
es leicht nach karamell riecht farben
kann ich nur in richen kommen jetzt die
gehobelte mandeln mir dazu denn jetzt
kräftig eingerührt hat mache ich jetzt
noch mal kurz an
auf mittlerer stufe kann ich so ein
bisschen an rüsten
[Musik]
und normalerweise nimmt man jetzt immer
so kleine häufchen und gibt sie auf dem
backblech und dann schmelzen und zu
laufen die im ofen zu kleinen tal an die
sind auch wirklich wunderschön gibt es
auch in bäckereien zum beispiel und auch
so fertig zu kaufen aber es fühlt sich
ziemlich mühsam jetzt diese ganzen
häufchen hier zu machen denn später muss
man sich dann einen hering oder zum
beispiel ein aussteller nehmen und noch
mal drüber legen und nochmal schön rund
formen
deswegen gibt es heute bei uns
praktische florentina und zwar werden
die dreiecke und dafür nehme ich jetzt
einen echten programmen können auch auf
einfach gleich zum beispiel machen
unterstreicht hier die komplette masse
einfach mal ein
und dann muss ich jetzt so nur eine
große platte backen und die später in
kleine stücke schneiden
[Musik]
das wird jetzt gleichmäßig verstrichen
meine hände nass dann merkt man die
hitze nicht so sehr
und wer das ganze nochmal gerd streichen
immer noch mal kurz in wasser tauchen
und laut strecke
[Musik]
und so wie jetzt die florentiner maße im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze etwa zwölf minuten gebacken
die oberfläche sollte dann schön braun
war richtig toll gerüstet die
florentiner sind jetzt gebacken und ich
habe sie etwa zehn minuten abkühlen
lassen aber sie sind immer noch warm
genug und noch nicht ganz fest
und jetzt sich das ersten hier runter
und löse den bug kamen mit einem
backform messer
[Musik]
also dürfte halt auf jeden fall nicht so
lange warten am besten nur fünf minuten
damit die masse einfach nicht zu fest
wird das herauslösen und schneiden
bisschen problematisch
also bei mir sieht man jetzt die platte
ist noch leicht flexibel und jetzt
schneide ich sie in rechtecke sie sind
dann etwa acht mal sechs zentimeter groß
[Musik]
und diese rechtecke schneide ich jetzt
noch in dreiecke
[Musik]
die florentiner ecken sind jetzt
abgekühlt und hier wollte ich euch noch
etwas zeigen und zwar mit backofen der
markt ja nicht ganz gleichmäßig deswegen
sieht man hier dass die flure die
nachher etwas heller sind und hier etwas
dunkler und die dunklen stellen wir sind
natürlich brüchig geworden weil sie
einfach zu stark karamellisiert sind
sieht mein ziel
das ist jetzt nicht schlimm aber ich
wollte ich nur sagen es ist sehr wichtig
den ofen zu beobachten das heißt bei mir
waren es zwölf minuten aber kann sein
dass in eurem backofen nur elf oder auch
13 minuten gebacken werden muss jetzt
habe ich hier 150 gramm peter corazza
bereits temperiert das heißt 100 gramm
über einem heißen aber nicht kommen ein
wasserbad erwärmt und geschmolzen und
dann einfach runter genommen und die
restlichen 50 eingeführt
jetzt werde ich die unterseite der
fiorentina damit bestreichen
ihr könnt sie gerne auch einen funken
aber das ist mir eine große sauerei und
dann setze ich sie auf die dauer back
folie und jetzt geht es zwar noch an
aber später wenn die schokolade fest
wird dann kann man sie ganz leicht
ablösen
[Musik]
so sehen die florentiner ecken jetzt aus
dem uran hat sie auch schon probiert ist
lecker aber der schutz grab samira ins
schwimmen fahren gegangen aber ich kann
acht profis für euch eigentlich will ich
finde ich schon aber ich probiere jetzt
für euch sind wirklich super lecker da
hört man bestimmt wie knackig die sind
oder und ich muss dazu sagen
als ich die florentiner masse ohne
zarter schokolade probiert habe hab ich
gedacht mensch mit der schokolade wird
vielleicht so süß aber die kuvertüre
passt wirklich perfekt dazu habe man
dieses süße diese süßen mandeln und dann
einfach diese herbe schokolade dazu und
ich würde auf jeden fall zar peter kurth
übernehmen und keine vollmilch ansonsten
wird es wirklich zu süß und mit der zahl
der korrektur ist wirklich der perfekte
snack freuen sich jetzt fast sagen aber
sich ganz energisch eine mega
kalorienbombe aber sehr lecker falls ihr
das rezept namen volt dann geht es -
nach dem da steht es noch mal für euch
und ich bringe jetzt in sicherheit denn
moralisch auch gleich wieder darf also
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]